.
I'LL SEE YOU LATER.
GOT TO GET TO BREAKING NEWS.
THIS IS "DON LEMON TONIGHT" AND
WE HAVE BREAKING NEWS.
THIS IS FROM THE SAME FEDERAL
JUDGE WHO BROKE NEWS LAST NIGHT
AT THIS TIME.
SHE IS SAYING SOME NEW STUFF.
BUT BASICALLY SHE IS SAYING,
STANDING BY, DOUBLING DOWN ON
WHAT SHE SAID LAST NIGHT.
SHE IS SAYING SHE WILL NOT HELP
THE FORMER PRESIDENT AS HE
ATTEMPTS TO BUY TIME ARGUING TO
KEEP RECORDS FROM HIS PRESIDENCY
SECRET.
SHE IS POINTING HIM INSTEAD TO
AN APPEALS COURT AS CHRIS JUST
MENTIONED.
SO THE JUNG'S LATEST DECISION
COME A DAY AFTER SHE RULED AGAIN
HIM IN A N HISTORIC CASE OVER
ACCESS O HIS PRESIDENCY SOUGHT
IN THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE
INVESTIGATION WRITING PRESIDENTS
ARE NOT KING AND PLAINTIFF IS
NOT PRESIDENT.
WITH THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES SET
TO SEND RECORDS OUT TO THE HOUSE
ON FRIDAY THE FORMER PRESIDENT
IS SCRAMBLING IN COURT FOR EVEN
A TEMPORARY HOLD.
SO LET'S GET RIGHT TO CNN'S
SENIOR LEGAL AFFAIRS
CORRESPONDENT, SENIOR POLITICAL
DIRECTOR, AND PROFESSOR OF LAW
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF BALTIMORE
SCHOOL OF LAW.
WE HAVE EK PERT MIND HERE O TALK
ABOUT THIS AND GET US THROUGH
THE BREAKING NEWS.
GOOD EVENING.
I'LL START WITH YOU FOR THE
REPORTING.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT DENIED
AGAIN IN THIS EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE CASE.
WHAT ARE YOU LEARNING?
>> YOU NOTED JUST LAST NIGHT
THIS IS THE SAME JUDGE THAT
RULED THAT FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP COULD NOT KEEP HIS WHITE
HOUSE RECORDS SECRET FROM THE
HOUSE SELECT COMMITTEE
INVESTIGATING JANUARY 6th.
NOW, THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES
INHERITED
INHERITED RUM PLEASE'S WHITE
HOUSE RECORDS AFTER HE LEFT
OFFICE AND THEY ARE SKEJ YOULD
ON FRIDAY O HAND OVER THIS GROUP
OF 700 PAGES OF WHITE HOUSE
RECORDS TO THE COMMITTEE.
TRUMP AND HIS ATTORNEYS ASKED
FOR THAT TO BE DELAYED WHILE HE
APPEAL.
IT IS NOT SURPRISING THE JUDGE
DENIED THE REQUEST.
NOW HE'LL LIKELY GO TO THE
APPELLATE COURT TO MAKE THE SAME
REQUEST.
IT WOULD BE SURPRISING IF THEY
DIDN'T GRAN IT.
>> BUT HE IS RUNNING OUT OF
OPTIONS O DELAY, RIGHT?
>> HE IS APPEALING THIS.
>> IF THEY'RE RUNNING OUT OF
TIME, ONLY ONE DAY, THIS JUDGE
BELIEVES HE HAS TIME.
GO TO THE APPEALS COURT AND TRY
IT YOURSELF.
>> NO WORRIES.
YOU ALSO HAVE A FEDERAL HOLIDAY.
HE HAS THE RIGHT TO GO TO THE
APPELLATE COURT AND ASK THEM TO
JUST PAUSE THE HAND-OFF OF THE
DOCUMENT WHILE THEY EXAMINE THE
LARGER CONSTITUTIONAL QUESTION.
THIS REALLY IS A PRETTY HISTORIC
CASE.
THERE ARE VERY NOVEL QUESTIONS
RAISED IN THIS CASE ABOUT THE
RIGHTS OF A FORMER PRESIDENT TO
KEEP HIS OR HER RECORDS
PROTECTED.
RIGHT NOW MOST OF THE POWER TO
PROTECT THE RECORDS OF FORMER
PRESIDENTS LIES WITH THE
INCUMBENT.
WE'VE SEEN HERE PRESIDENT BIDEN
HAS DECLINED TO PROTECT THESE
DOCUMENTS AND THAT IS WHERE WE
GET THIS CASE.
SO FAR IT IS NOT LOOKING GREAT
FOR FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP BUT
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS AT THE
APPELLATE COURT LEVEL AND
WHOEVER LOSES THERE WOULD LIKELY
WANT TO APPEAL TO THE SUPREME
COURT.
WHETHER THEY'LL TAKE IT UP I
KNOW ONE OF OUR EARLIER
COLLEAGUES SAID THEY DIDN'T SEE
A QUESTION HERE.
I DISAGREE.
THIS IS A NOVEL CONSTITUTIONAL
QUESTION THE SUPREME COURT MAY
WANT TO TAKE UP.
>> STAND BY, PAULA.
I WANT TO BRING IN THE OTHER
FOLKS HERE.
KIM, GIVE ME YOUR REACTION TO
WHAT THE JUDGE IS DOING
REJECTING THIS SAYING TRYING TO
BUY -- HE IS TRYING TO BUY TIME
AND SHE IS SAYING I'M NOT GOING
TO HELP YOU WITH THAT.
>> UNDER THE RULES OF FEDERAL
APPELLATE PROCEDURE RULE 8 IF
TRUMP WANTS A STAY FROM THE
COURT OF APPEALS THE RULES DO
REQUIRE THAT HE FIRST ASK THE
DISTRICT COURT JUDGE FOR THE
STAY.
SO IT IS ALMOST LIKE AN
EXHAUSTION PROCESS.
HAD TO GO TO HER FIRST AND THEN
HAS TO MAKE THE SAME SHOWING TO
THE APPELLATE COURT THAT SHE
REJECTED.
THAT IS A FOUR PART TEST THAT
INCLUDES A SHOWING OF WHAT WE
CALL LIKELIHOOD OF SUCCESS ON
THE MERITS.
HE HAS TO SHOW HE'LL PROBABLY
WIN HIS APPEAL AND THAT IS THE
WEAKEST PART IN MY MIND.
BUT I HAVE TO AGREE WITH PAULA
ON THE SUPREME COURT HERE AS
WELL.
>> HOLD ON.
WHY DO YOU SAY THAT IS THE
WEAKEST IN YOUR MIND?
>> THAT IS THE WEAKEST IN MY
MIND BECAUSE THE PRESIDENTIAL
RECORDS ACT UNDER WHICH THIS
LAWSUIT IS BROUGHT IS A POST
WATERGATE REFORM SPECIFICALLY
DESIGNED TO BYPASS PRESIDENT
NIXON'S ATTEMPTS TO ESSENTIALLY
POTENTIALLY DESTROY RECORDS AND
MAINTAIN RECORDS.
AND THE UNITED STATES CONGRESS
SAID, NO.
THE RECORDS BELONG TO THE
PEOPLE.
THE INCUMBENT PRESIDENT JOE
BIDEN IS THE HOLDER OF THE
PEOPLE'S INTERESTS.
THIS IS REALLY ABOUT THE PUBLIC
INTEREST IN THIS MOTION.
>> GOT IT.
>> SO DONALD TRUMP HAS TO ARGUE
HE IS MORE IN TUNE WITH THE
PUBLIC INTEREST THAN THE UNITED
STATES PRESIDENT UNDER THE
CONSTITUTION.
I THINK THAT IS A REALLY TOUGH
SELL.
>> OKAY.
SO WHAT IF THE JUDGE HAD TAKEN
HER SWEET TIME?
DID SHE HAVE TO ACT WITH URGENCY
HERE OR COULD SHE HAVE TAKEN HER
TIME AND SAID ON FRIDAY I'M
SORRY YOU GOT TO GO TO THE
APPEALS COURT?
>> THERE IS NOTHING MANDATING
SHE DO IT IN ANY PARTICULAR
AMOUNT OF TIME.
>> SHE DID IT IN DEFERENCE TO
THE --
>> YEAH, TO THE APPELLATE COURT.
SHE KNOWS THIS IS ALL EYES ON
THIS AND THE OPINION WAS
RELATIVELY BRIEF.
SHE NAILED EVERYTHING.
IT WAS A VERY TIGHTLY WORDED,
VERY, VERY WELL DONE OPINION.
SHE KNOWS WHAT SHE IS TALKING
ABOUT.
>> ONE MORE QUESTION BEFORE I
GET TO DAVID.
WHAT ARE YOU EXPECTING WHEN
TRUMP GETS TO THE APPEALS COURT
AGAIN, THE D.C. CIRCUIT COURT OF
APPEALS AGAIN?
>> I DID A LITTLE RESEARCH ON
THIS IN SORT OF THE LEGAL
SCHOLARSHIP FIELD.
IT IS RARE TO GET THE STATE THAT
HE WANTS.
IT IS IN LESS THAN, IN A 2020
STUDY LESS THAN 20% OF THE CASES
ACTUALLY GET WHAT HE IS ASKING
FOR BUT TEND TO BE A HIGHER
PERCENTAGE IF ASKING TO STAY
RELEASE OF CONFIDENTIAL
DOCUMENTS.
SO I DO THINK IT IS POSSIBLE
THAT THE COURT OF APPEALS IS
GOING TO SAY THIS IS IMPORTANT.
WE'LL ISSUE THE STAY.
ALTERNATIVELY THEY COULD JUST
SAY WE AGREE WITH THE LOWER
COURT.
YOU HAVE NOT SATISFIED THE
STANDARD FOR INJUNCTION.
WE ARE GOING TO BRIEFLY DENY THE
WHOLE THING.
THAT IS CONCEIVABLE.
IT DOES DEPEND ON THE PANEL, THE
JUDGES THAT ARE GOING TO DECIDE
THIS.
>> DAVID, LET'S BRING YOU IN
HERE, OUR POLITICAL DIRECTOR AND
KNOWS ALL THINGS POLITICS.
WITHOUT EMERGENCY RELIEF FROM
THE D.C. CIRCUIT COURT.
>> YEAH, PLEASE DO NOT ASK ME
ABOUT APPELLATE PROCEDURES.
>> I'LL ASK YOU ABOUT THE
POLITICAL ANGLE.
IT IS 40 PAGES.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT ARE THEY
HIDING?
WHAT COULD WE LEARN FROM THESE
WHITE HOUSE RECORDS?
WHO KNOWS?
THERE IS A WHOLE BEVY OF THINGS.
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, WE KNOW WHAT THE
COMMITTEE IS INTERESTED IN
RIGHT?
WE KNOW THAT THE COMMITTEE IS
INTERESTED IN PIECING TOGETHER
THE BUILD UP TO JANUARY 6th, THE
PLOTTING AND PLANNING, AND WHO
WAS INVOLVED WITH THAT AND HOW
CLOSE DID THAT GET TO PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND WAS HE DIRECTLY
INVOLVED IN ANY WAY.
THE DAY, ITSELF.
EVERYTHING THAT WAS GOING ON
AROUND THE PRESIDENT ON THE 6th
OF JANUARY.
AND OF COURSE THE AFTERMATH.
SO WE KNOW THAT THEY'RE
INTERESTED IN FINDING OUT SORT
OF PRECISELY THROUGH THOSE DAYS
LEADING UP AND THE DAY OF THE
PRESIDENT'S MOVEMENTS.
WHO WAS AROUND HIM.
WHAT WERE THE CONVERSATIONS
TAKING PLACE?
YOU MENTIONED, YOU KNOW, IT IS
UP TO THE CURRENT PRESIDENT TO
ASSERT PRIVILEGE.
JOE BIDEN MADE A REALLY BIG
DECISION A COUPLE WEEKS AGO WHEN
HE CAME TO THE CONCLUSION THAT
HE WAS NOT GOING TO ASSERT
PRIVILEGE.
WE KNOW AND THE WHITE HOUSE
ASSERTED AGAIN TODAY IN A
STATEMENT, DON, THAT JOE BIDEN
IS COMMITTED TO A FULL COUNTING
OF WHAT OCCURRED IN THE BUILD UP
TO AND ON JANUARY 6th SO THE
COUNTRY CAN PREVENT AN ATTACK ON
THE DEMOCRACY LIKE THAT EVER
AGAIN.
BUT STILL THIS WAS A WEIGHTY DOE
SIGS.
IT IS GOING TO SET A PRECEDENT
WHICH NO DOUBT HE AND WHITE
HOUSE COUNSEL WERE VERY MUCH
THINKING THROUGH BUT HE CAME TO
THE CONCLUSION THE TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THIS
GREATEST ATTACK ON OUR DEMOCRACY
TRUMPED, PARDON THE PUN, ANY
CLAIM THAT THE FORMER PRESIDENT
MAY HAVE RELATING TO PRIVILEGE.
>> ANOTHER POLITICAL QUESTION
HERE.
BECAUSE THE CONCERN OBVIOUSLY
OVER POLITICS IS RUNNING OUT THE
CLOCK.
THE 2022 MIDTERMS ARE COMING
VERY SOON.
CONGRESS COULD CHANGE HANDS.
COULD HE RUN OUT THE CLOCK ON
THIS?
>> I MEAN, WE'LL HAVE TO SEE HOW
LENGTHY, NOT JUST THIS
PARTICULAR APPEALS PROCESS IS ON
PRIVILEGE, BUT THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRETY OF THE EXISTENCE OF THE
COMMITTEE.
OBVIOUSLY THEY'VE ISSUED A BUNCH
OF SUBPOENAS.
WE KNOW PEOPLE HAVE NOT BEEN
COMPLYING WITH THOSE SUBPOENAS
BASED ON GUIDANCE AND COUNSEL
AND ADVICE FROM DONALD TRUMP
TRYING TO SORT OF APPEASE THE
DESIRES OF THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
SO CLEARLY THERE IS A CLOCK HERE
THAT THE TRUMP TEAM WILL TRY TO
RUN OUT.
BUT, DON, THE COMMITTEE IS KEENL
AWARE CONGRESS MAY CHANGE HANDS
NEXT NOVEMBER AND COME NEXT
JANUARY REPUBLICANS COULD BE IN
CHARGE OF THE HOUSE.
NO DOUBT THEY ARE GOING TO BE
SETTING A TIMETABLE HERE TO
COMPLETE THEIR WORK SOONER
RATHER THAN LATER IN 2022.
THEY HAVE NO DESIRE FOR THIS TO
GO INTO THE NEXT CONGRESS.
>> ONE MORE, DAVID.
BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW, CNN IS
EXCLUSIVELY LEARNING THAT THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE IS
INTERESTED IN TALKING WITH AT
LEAST FIVE PEOPLE FROM MIKE
PENCE'S INNER CIRCLE THE FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT.
SOME APPEAR TO BE ENGAGING WITH
THE COMMITTEE AND WE ALL
REMEMBER THE VIDEO OF PENCE
BEING RUSHED OUT TO SAFETY.
LOOK, IT'S BEEN SORT OF BACK AND
FORTH WITH MIKE PENCE STANDING
UP REALLY FOR THE CONSTITUTION
AND FOR FREE AND FAIR ELECTIONS
AND ALSO SAYING IN ANOTHER, WITH
ANOTHER VOICE OR FROM ANOTHER
SIDE OF HIS MOUTH AND PRAISING
THE FORMER PRESIDENT IN SPEECHES
AND WHAT HAVE YOU.
IF THESE FOLKS ARE WANTING TO
COMPLY AND WANTING TO TESTIFY
AND MEET WITH THE COMMITTEE HOW
WORRIED SHOULD TRUMP BE PENCE'S
INNER CIRCLE COULD TESTIFY?
>> RIGHT.
IT IS NO SURPRISE THAT THE
COMMITTEE WANTS TO TALK TO AIDES
VERY CLOSE TO VICE PRESIDENT,
THEN VICE PRESIDENT PENCE.
WHAT I THOUGHT WAS SO INCREDIBLE
IN THE REPORTING THAT WE HAD
TODAY ON THIS WAS EXACTLY THIS
NOTION, DON, THAT THERE ARE
EAGER PEOPLE IN PENCE WORLD TO
TELL THEIR STORY.
IT IS CLEAR, YOU MENTIONED THE
VIDEO OF HIM BEING USHERED OUT.
IT IS CLEAR THAT THE COMMITTEE
IS VERY INTERESTED IN